hello everyone and welcome to Round
seven of the London chess classic this
is a this is a pretty wild game between
young upon yashi and Vishwanathan Anand
you'll see what I mean by wild the napo
has the white pieces and he plays C for
the English opening Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 e six Knight to f3
b5 III a6 b3 Bishop to d6 Bishop to b2
and in this position under castles and I
don't think castling in this position is
a mistake but it allows a nipper to go
for this very aggressive and early
this is move seven to go for this g4 so
you'll see how the game ends up with but
maybe instead of castling here perhaps
b6 and then after d4 Bishop to b7 simply
waiting for white they decide what he
wants to do with a light square bishop
and then if he develops at the Daniel
castle maybe I don't know I don't know
if g4 is is aligned so Ananse castles
and nympho goes for g4 you do have to
capture it
I mean you can't allow a move like g5 so
Knight captures rook to g1 now and f5
other than f5 you can also go for
something like e fives and after C
capture somebody for now Knight to f6
which is probably probably just as good
but white will get an open file open G
file for the rook either way but that's
the roof did you want on and decided to
go for f5 c capture sun defy the end now
e5 and okay he does have a pawn on e5
pawn on f5 it it doesn't seem bad for
black h3 kicking the night away Knight
f6 and Knight to g5 now and it's very
hard to get rid of this night unless you
want to weaken your Kings position with
h6 and even if you do this the night is
coming to e6 either way so Queen to e7
Queen to f3 and the key to h8 now 9 3 6
Bishop captures pawn captures and Queen
captures allowing Queen captures and
visa
Knight B to d7 by Anand and Bishop to c4
would a temple on the Queen Queen to e7
and now Queen back to g2 to pressure the
g7 pawn Knight to b6 attacking the
bishop and the bishop back to e2 a five
now and now nepo returns the Bishop to
b5 as this is a much more active square
for the Bishop rook a to the 8th we have
Queen to g5 now and g6 Queen to h6 we
have nice the g8 put a temple on the
Queen and Queen to g5 offering a trade
of Queens and Allen refuses a trade of
Queens
he plays Knight to f6 if Queen captures
rook captures then it's a it's a it's a
better position for white you're going
to break open the position with h4 h5
you do have the bishops pair and it's a
it's a nice position f4 is coming the
bishop is on b2 King and h8 it's
slightly better for white probably on
earth could have gone for this but he
decided to keep the Queen's on the board
after paint the g5 Knight to f6 now rook
to d1 e for and Queen to h6 now rook the
g8 rook captures on g6 was a threat so
roof 2g defending and 1992 now opening
up the bishops attack on the knight not
interested in capturing the night but
just pinning it so the knight can't move
Bishop to e5 now offering to exchange
this powerful Bishop and b2 Bishop
captures Queen captures and Knight to f4
and here aren't played g5 as the threat
is of course Knight captures on g6 you
can't capture with the H pawn and you'd
have to give up the exchange so there
are two ways that you can go about this
you can either play g5 what I don't
played or you can try capturing this
bishop that Napo is offering so lightly
if you capture the bishop with Queen
captures on b5 then Knight captures on
g6 rook captures rook captures
threatening of course
Queen to g7 checkmate and after up the
g8 rock actress Knight captures and the
Queen to e6 and after something like
between to c5 d 4e captures rook after
Sundy three it's a pretty equal position
probably on earth could have gone for
this but he decided not to it's very
hard to say if white can if white can
make progress here it's like if I could
somehow untangle the two nights are
great but I don't know rope to the eight
is coming and how do you stop this I
probably have to play something like
team to g7 to get to get back into the
game so I decided not to go for this
instead of capturing the Bishop of Queen
Queen captures on b5 he played g5
allowing what characters on g5 route
captures and g5 20 actor Sanjeev AB and
now rook the g8 Queen to h6
and now again you can't capture the
bishop you if you capture the bishop you
lose the night Queen captures Rob comes
to g7 and you're getting check made it
Queen to f8 check comes here now Knight
to g6 check H captures on g6 and Queen
to h6 checkmate
so instead after Queen to h6 instead of
capturing the Bishop of the g7 now and
Bishop to c4 and Knight captures and c4
b captures on c4 and queen to be - now
going after that a to pawn and wants to
create a passed pawn this this a passed
pawn so King - E - a for now Knight the
e6 we have route to f7 getting broke out
of the way Knight back to a for roof to
g7 now and now a three and not allowing
the Queen captured on a two and stopping
the pond from going further to a three
and doping can't capture of course the
knight is hanging here and and has a
couple of options here it's it's very
hard to find a move iron plate the nice
to e8 which which loses immediately the
Queen to c6
attacking the knight on e8 and the
corner a four and no matter what you do
here you lose the pawn and a four but
the problem is even if not Knight to c8
Knight to d7 also loses the Queen to c6
but even if you play something like
Queen to b6 to protect the night
then comes rook to be one attacking the
Queen if you if you move the Queen
you're either getting rook to b8 check
or if you stop defending the knight then
you lose the night but if you capture
the rook Queen captures now Queen
captures knight on f6 you don't really
have a way of dealing with White's
threats either you stay here with the
Queen for the entire game and allow
White Queen to clean up all the pawns or
you move the Queen from from eyeing the
d3 square and then comes either Knight
to d6 we're attacking the rook or Knight
to h5 would an attack on the rook and
white will win this King and pawn and
game start after this a to remove and
play tonight the e8 and have to point to
c6 and resigned the game what what
follow is on and it does have a couple
of moves here I don't know if this was a
problem it was I mean ready ready for
resignation the thread is either
capturing the knight or upon an a4 if
you play something like Knight to d6 you
lose the pawn on a for now Napo is up
two points and after sounds like roof to
g8 you have to play something then this
c5 move comes Knight moves and for
example Queen before exchanged Queens
and a rook and Knight with two pawns up
is completely winning for white and it
doesn't want to play this so after
putting the c6 you do have a couple of
other options for example rook to g8 to
defend again you'll lose the pawn and
doesn't really matter what you play
again c5 you'll get pretty much the same
thing and the one other thing after
Queen to c6 could go for something like
Queen to e5 to defend the night but
again it changes nothing simply Queen
captures on a four row bg8 rook the b1
going for going for rook to b8 and after
97 Queen to c6 you
you have to play something probably
exchange Queens and again it's a winning
game game but I don't know what do you
think would you would you play this
position on with the black pieces would
you try to fight it with being down 2
points as the tournament is almost over
there are two more rounds and nepo is
now I believe in first place tied in
first place with Fabiano Caruana so it's
gonna be it's gonna be a feisty
tournament if you know if if there will
be more games like this I believe this
is the fourth win of the tournament so
far so yeah very very interesting fourth
win of the entire tournament so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and what do you think if you've seen the
Magnus Carlsen versus Hikaru Nakamura
yesterday course and played you know as
he was pretty sick he played that
terrible terrible end game he refused to
resign resign it and he continued to
play it and in the end he drew the game
and there were a couple of moments were
where I actually thought that he was
gonna win so what do you think would
cost and continue this end game would
black so yeah once again I think all for
watching as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and I will see
you soon